[Laughter]
hey everybody happy sunday
so yeah uh we went out last night so we
didn't get to watch a movie so i said
well [ __ ] it we'll just do a but another
side track show we had a pretty good
time
it was pretty fun uh
oh yeah right there hiccupping
okay
yeah we went down to uh mannequins
now i had thought
that and i guess he's kind of doing this
but i had kind of thought that they were
going like more in 80s new wave like on
saturday nights because they were you
know since barbarella moved
but
it started out like that like he played
a bunch of 80s new wave and stuff like
that but then it started going more into
like their old format which was what the
[ __ ] saturdays which is like they'll
just play anything yeah cause then they
started playing he was reading the crowd
yeah you had a lot of what the [ __ ]
people in there uh yeah it was pretty
much all what the [ __ ] people
that was a little um
yeah like toward the end of the night
this was like so bizarre like toward the
end of the night there was like i guess
it was a pub crawl because you know how
they do those themed pub crawls right
and i guess the
the theme was cruise ship yeah so you
had all of these like douchey
yeah 20 somethings wearing like captain
stubbing hats and like white shorts and
hawaiian shirts
and lays and stuff like that yeah it
looked like the [ __ ] love boat all up
in there yeah and then it was so bizarre
i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
like why all these people have like
cruise ship captain apps it's funny this
is florida so it blends in
it doesn't look that odd
not real i mean it was the hats that
stood out if they were just wearing the
[ __ ] that they were wearing it wouldn't
have stood i knew i knew it was it was
some kind of an event
yeah but it kind of just looks like uh
you know they're touring because they're
just tourists everywhere you know
yeah yeah i'm stupid
i knew there was costumes it kind of
looked cheap you know it didn't look
real but yeah
and yeah i guess like toward the end of
the night like they had a they were
going on a bus i guess because like this
big bus came and like picked them all up
but uh yeah that was pretty funny we
just i don't know it's just it seemed
like the music was really good at the
beginning
like i said it was kind of more 80s new
wave type stuff and then it started
going i guess like more once more the
douchey people started dancing we're
calling them douchey people well you
know she's talking about jocks
that's who's called about the tasty
people they're not jokes they're like
yuppies yeah like when they started
getting out on the floor then he started
going more toward like he started
playing like [ __ ] uh
like you know sir mix a lot and yeah
[ __ ] like vanilla ice cream
mundanes we call them mundanes well
there's different words different kind
of mundane they're just one of the
mundanes
there was a lot of different groups
everybody so then we had to so after
that like when when it started going
that direction we had to go out into the
[ __ ] we went out on the patio and
they have a different dj out there and
he usually plays kind of
kind of dark wave and uh not yeah
industrial
he was what was he playing out there
like [ __ ] uh
covenant and [ __ ]
thrill kill cult and [ __ ] like that so
so we went out there for a little while
but then i went back in to go to the
bathroom and the bee gees were on so
then i ran out this whole time like the
beaches are on so we had to go in and
dance with the moon
and then and abba
he played dancing
[Laughter]
it was pretty awesome it was pretty
awesome fourth throw down says uh or
miami vice extras night it was like so
weird i will never understand
that whole
because remember that one guy there and
i was just like looking at him like i
don't understand like why you would
leave the house like wearing that like
or you know i don't not that you would
wouldn't leave the house like wearing
that but why would you like go to a
nightclub wearing that like those kind
of like knee-length white shorts yeah
and like that's part of the pumpkin but
i'm not sure that's what i mean i
couldn't tell he didn't have like a he
didn't have a hat on a golf shirt you
know what i mean like some eyes odd
shirt this is that's what they wear you
know and then like with a collar on it
and then like white kind of shoes with
no socks yeah
not voting but you know
just like all right man
i don't know i guess it's an upper
middle class lower upper class thing i
don't know i think rich people don't
really give a [ __ ] what they look like
um but
because they're like [ __ ] you they got
[ __ ] you money
it's just uh
that's the clothes they grew up with so
that's what they're gonna wear i i think
they uh
they're gonna say that that's what they
wear i guess you know i don't know i i
can't i mean we wear what we wear
they're gonna wear what they're they're
wearing yeah i wouldn't tell them like
they're not allowed to wear that you
know i'm just i'm just saying i'm
silently i'm silently judging from my
from my point of view last character you
know i mean it's just very generic yeah
very bland
it doesn't really say anything you know
to me
well you know it says i'm i'm a really
bland boring class yeah
that's what it says so it does but they
don't see themselves that way they take
their life for the party you know what i
mean they're just like oh man dude well
yeah that's yeah and then that's well
that's when we've talked about that
before like those kind of people
wouldn't bother me
if they just came in and acted like
normal and knew how to behave
but they don't they always come in and
they're just like woo
and they always have to like look at me
and they're like
there's nothing to see there's nothing
to say
i was like just shut up and be normal
goddamn and they had like five guys come
in in their 20s [ __ ] white guys and
and they were all kind of dressed like
that
and [ __ ] not a one of them was under
six foot two they were like six three
six four
random dudes
yeah i think i saw one well yeah i saw
one of them because i had to like reach
around and get my because i have my
drink was over there and i'm like would
you move they were all [ __ ] super
tall
you know and i was looking at them i was
like man these basketball players or
something [ __ ] you know white
basketball players maybe college or
something but they didn't look like they
were in real good shape really to me you
know maybe they're just tall guys that
hang out together yeah i guess you know
it's a tall guy club it's a tall guy
club yeah because there are short guy
clubs
[Laughter]
yeah i wonder if they're a tall guy
clothes it must be the tall guy glove
where you know just as tom cruise
there's all kinds of short guy clubs
he's in every one of them
[Laughter]
they probably don't call it that no him
and david miscavige they're their own
club yeah yeah him and david mosque
those terrible yeah
yeah speaking of tom cruise we're going
to have to go see i guess we're gonna
have to go see that top top gun movie
we're gonna go see we were actually
gonna go see fire starters yesterday
but tom was like i don't want to go
anywhere on a saturday right around so
look how she did my voice in that voice
yeah that's not how i sound well that's
how you sound to me when you're when
you're when you're complaining about
something
no i'm just trying to i wasn't trying to
be like that's what you sound like i was
just trying to convey
that to me it just always sounds like
you're complaining about you didn't want
to go
so we're going to go tomorrow i guess
and see fire starter hugo said i just
watched the northmen i'm going to store
storage it between beowulf and eric the
viking man eric the viking i haven't
seen that in a really long time
holy i don't know that's good or bad i
don't know
i remember i had i remember the the cg
beywolf that was pretty good without the
voice acting i think it's what he's
talking about it's pretty good
a lot better than that
though yeah beowulf was it was good but
it was like i guess it wasn't supposed
to be realistic it was supposed to be
like like a
mythical type of [ __ ] yeah
it was just it was a little uncanny
valley but it was like it was okay
otherwise
right
i watched a really good movie today i'm
gonna do i'm gonna i don't want to talk
too much about it because i'm gonna
record a review for it tomorrow but
um i'd actually been hearing like a lot
of buzz about this one it's a movie it's
from taiwan
and uh it's called the sadness has
anybody seen that i think it's on amazon
prime i watched it on shutter though
um it is a [ __ ]
bloodbath if you're really into like
gore
holy [ __ ]
you need to like it's [ __ ] brutal
it's really [ __ ] up and i think it's
all practical effects
so
just a heads up if you're really really
into like really violent horror films
it's kind of like an infection type film
like uh like 28 days later or the crazy
it's not zombies but it's what's it
called again the sadness i didn't see it
you saw it yeah i watched it earlier oh
because i was i was going to do a review
for it
i had just heard it was like really
really [ __ ] up and like really really
gory and i was like oh okay that sounds
like a recommendation and uh indeed it
is very very [ __ ] up and corey i
really enjoyed it quite a bit poogie's
gonna try to get on the show you're
gonna try to get on the show you want to
be on the show pokey come here
oh she keeps looking at me all right um
yeah so uh we went out
yeah and then we had to of course of
course we had to hit mcdonald's on the
way home yeah
yeah i was kind of laughing because he
was the man he's going no you didn't
matter
i thought it was like
you tell the story well yeah well we go
to the drive-through we were gonna go to
one mcdonald's but i think it was closed
or it was too crowded or something like
that so then we went to another one that
less people know about
so we went to that one and i was kind of
mad because i wanted a crispy chicken
sandwich but like in the middle of the
night even on saturday nights they don't
do chicken so i'm like what you don't do
you don't do chicken [ __ ] yeah
they don't do chicken in the middle of
the night so i had to get a quarter
pounder instead but you would you
ordered and i don't remember like what
you said exactly that i said i said uh
do you still have that thing where you
get two too uh big big back six dollars
and he's like yeah this is let me get
that and she goes okay i get it that
says you are the man
and he goes no you're the man
it was like immediate no you're the man
yeah
so i get up there
at the cashier
and he's a young black guy in his 20s
with long flats going all the way
down yeah they went down to his elbow
didn't it
i think i didn't see him i didn't see
him all that good
and i'm painting and i says oh by the
way you are the man and he goes no you
demand
[Laughter]
no you're the man and then i said i said
man you i said you got mcdonald's at two
o'clock in the morning that means you're
the man yeah you're right
yeah you're right yeah you're right
you know then it comes back
and he goes it
comes back and says some [ __ ] like
you're still the man no and i said i'm
53 years old and i'm telling you that
you are the [ __ ] man
yeah we got into the year the man fight
he's like dad you look young
he goes all right i'm the man
that's
[Laughter]
it was pretty [ __ ] fun yeah
just it just happened without thinking
about it
yeah i was kind of you know it's always
nice to go through the mcdonald's drive
through the middle of the night because
i always for some reason i always want
mcdonald's when i'm drunk i either want
mcdonald's or
breakfast you know what i mean like eggs
or something like mcdonald's night crew
on fridays and saturdays deals with the
drunk crowd and they always got they
seem to have the best people for it
because they'll [ __ ] with you over the
intercoms yeah they're having a good
time having a good time and [ __ ] with
you they know what's happening i mean
they're probably high too yeah
as long as everything moves fast it's
i'm happy
yeah i mean it did i mean it was messy
it was busy like um but they they worked
it out pretty fast and everything like
all the the fries were fresh even yeah
which is always nice oh yeah those uh
those two big macs they were all [ __ ]
fluffy and [ __ ] like the the bread was
[ __ ] fat and fluffy
freshly assembled
fat the patties are getting thinner and
thinner though it's just like two meat
stripes in it now though it's not even
patties it's just meat strawberry meat
stripe
[Laughter]
kind of like something that they peeled
off like paper
like a slice of bacon or something
there's barely any hamburger on them now
mine was okay though it's just it's just
lettuce
and that sauce and the bread that's what
gives you that big mac experience and
the pickles to be honest um i'm gonna
take a stand on this hill i think the
quarter pounder is a superior hamburger
to the big mac i like them both yeah
they're both good yeah i'm just saying
that if i had to pick which one was
better
uh the quarter pounder i think is a more
substantial it's more like a hamburger
yeah a big mac is just a big mac yeah
it's it's own thing i mean the sauce is
good like the big mac sauce is good but
i think if you actually just want like
uh
the ideal burger experience at
mcdonald's i think the quarter pound
area should go to
i'm just saying big mac's good too but
and we also then we had um
you know
tom had beef thawed so we had another
burger again today yeah yeah i found it
stalled down here
i got it i get out of there to get it
like the fatty's like this thick and i
was like nice
it was so big and it was like nice and
um nice and rare because i like them
like medium rare to rare
and i had to eat it with um a knife and
fork though because it was like so big
and sticky basically yeah but it was
like delicious yeah
it was good it had uh guacamole on it
yeah
yeah
the only thing didn't have mustard on it
but it just had mayo ketchup guacamole
i'm not a huge fan of mustard i like
i'll eat mustard on a burger but if
i'm you know if i'm putting condiments
on it yeah i don't know i know you don't
like it so i leave it yeah i'm not
really a big fan of it
well it's not that i don't like it it's
just that i'm kind of meh about it it's
like i'd rather not have it but if it's
on there it's not that big a deal i'll
eat it
man the only thing better than guacamole
on a burger is like a fried egg on a
burger yeah those are good too goddamn
that's delicious
slasher fred there was a movie from the
2000s called shadow of the vampire yeah
that's right that movie is uh amazing
that is a biography like about the
making of nosferatu yeah willem dafoe
was in that and uh
john malkovich
uh yeah really really good yeah a whole
what mac shrek was really a vampire
thing
tammy says we're getting a thunderstorm
here we had one here earlier
i think it's not raining now but it was
raining earlier and like uh
you know thundering and [ __ ]
um fourth through down anyone working at
2am and still got a sense of humor is
probably the man yeah i agree i agree
i mean because i've never worked at
mcdonald's but my brother worked there
and i had a friend that worked there for
many years
and
that's kind of a hard job and i'm sure
they have to deal with a lot of [ __ ]
and especially like the middle of the
night i imagine they probably deal with
a bunch of [ __ ] although maybe the
middle of the night's not as bad because
maybe it's not as crowded maybe maybe
everyone's kind of chill i'm not
entirely sure
john smith said best thing at mcdonald's
the vegetarian burger they never get
asked for it so have to make it up
special and it's very good
yeah a lot of times they'll tell you to
order something that doesn't really get
ordered much because then they have to
make it instead of like put although
mcdonald's doesn't do the heat lamp
thing anymore do they i don't know i
don't
they do those little bins that they
slide it through yeah but i think i
don't really know because i thought like
a few years ago they kind of changed
because of competition like from fast
casual restaurants where people were
like you know making your [ __ ] like
right then yeah um you know because for
a long time mcdonald's and it wasn't
just mcdonald's burger king and
everybody did that but they would make a
bunch of burgers like a head and then
put them in the heat lamp and then they
would sit there and get nasty yeah so i
don't think they do that anymore you see
um
computerization has made the ordering
process and the [ __ ] assembly process
a lot easier you don't need people
yelling everywhere and you know and
[ __ ] yelling to some [ __ ] head
cook who's looking trying to organize it
all there's screens so it shows of what
to do and what to assemble on each order
and what has to go out so it's they got
it they got it down to where it works
like like a like a machine you know like
a robot
yeah it is like much better that's why
it moves so quickly now
well and plus a lot of people are
ordering like through apps and they're
sort of ordering you can order on the
screen like some mcdonald's not i don't
think the but the one that we that used
to be by our old house had the screens
where you could just come in and order
like on the screen and then you could
just pick it up if you didn't like
happening you know what order in which
to do things so it keeps it all
organized
tammy says burger king's impossible
whopper is good it is i got one one time
just out of curiosity i mean i'm not a
vegetarian but i just wanted to see if i
chose it like and it was actually pretty
deep right it's pretty decent the thing
is is that i would never buy another one
just because uh the price
yeah if it's a vegetable if it's
vegetable product it should be a
fraction of what meat would cost i'm not
going to pay more
for a vegetarian yeah
but it's nice for like vegetarians and
vegans to have that option right
you know what i mean because i even
remember like back in the 70s and 80s i
knew a couple people that were
vegetarians and it was like a pain in
the ass like because most restaurants
didn't even have like a single
vegetarian option
other than like a side salad
and even then like a lot of times i
don't know um if a lot of people knew
but even some dressings and stuff like
that aren't vegetarian because they have
like anchovies or something like that in
there
so
they didn't really have a lot of options
so it's much easier nowadays to
kind of get what you want
speaking of breakfast have you seen
falling down with michael douglas yeah i
did like a long time ago i kind of want
to like re-watch it it's been like so
many years since i saw it i think i
might have seen it in the theater now
that i'm thinking about it
um
peter says my wife was a breakfast
manager there many many years ago at
mcdonald's i'm assuming
yeah i don't know i just i've never um i
don't think i've ever actually worked in
food service i've worked in retail like
i used to work at a record store
but
yeah i don't think i i never worked at a
restaurant i never worked in fast food
yeah i worked in restaurants but never
fast food
my brother worked in restaurants he
worked in mcdonald's he worked at
bennigan's which i don't think is around
anymore
and some other places but
i don't i've never i've heard that a
modern mcdonald's is like a good place
to work it's just it's just because
everything is so streamlined and
modernized it's not like working in a
traditional kitchen where it's super
[ __ ] hot like you know spilling damn
boiling oil everywhere you know it's not
as bad
because they just have everything just
kind of
adjusted for people who kind of are not
cooks they're just food assemblers you
know
so this is not like a passion of theirs
so everything has to be kind of made as
simple and streamlined as possible to
get that job done and evidently it's
they say it's kind of i don't say fun
but easy very easy
i imagine it's probably much easier than
it used to be yes
a traditional kitchen is kind of like
air traffic control you're sitting there
trying to organize everything a head
chef's [ __ ] yelling and screaming
there's a bunch of pre-planning involved
you're working hours before the
restaurant even opens up to [ __ ] do
things like i can get salads ready or
salad toppings or to start baking things
that are going to be used for the red
for the
for the day
[ __ ] setting up steam tables and
stuff there's just a lot of [ __ ] that
has to happen
and um
and then when it's go time man it's
[ __ ] confusing to keep all that [ __ ]
in order and it all has to come up at
the right time
there's an art to it yeah i mean i can
imagine i've i've watched enough gordon
ramsay in another you know shows about
like how restaurants run because i'm
fascinated with how restaurants run but
it is like a very very high stress yeah
probably not fast food but like regular
rice yeah
basically two teams working together
you know the kitchen and then front of
house you know all the the way the wait
staff
and you know the the hostesses and the
damn managers and
they've got to work together like a
well-oiled team and a lot of [ __ ] can go
wrong
well there's so many moving parts yeah
you know and you never know from day to
day because you never know like who's
going to show up or what they're going
to want or
how [ __ ] it's going to go you're the
kitchen and you [ __ ] something up on a
damn order and then the waitress takes
the blame for it she didn't make it yeah
you know and then she loses tips
you know it's uh
they don't do that much anymore just
that only an [ __ ] would penalize the
the waitress for something that the cook
did
and and i
you know
those [ __ ] are few and far between
but you are kind of like jeopardizing
them you know they shouldn't have to
even hear any complaints
from a customer yeah because like i said
they didn't make it right i mean it'd be
one thing if they made a mistake but if
this if your food's cold or some [ __ ]
like that like the the [ __ ] server
didn't do that yeah well they're making
mistakes too yeah and that's what i'm
saying they're making mistakes they're
making mistakes you know people getting
blamed for each other
i don't know i'm just kind of like
as long as as long as it's just a
mistake and it wasn't done with malice i
mean there's really no reason to get
like all [ __ ] bent out of shape about
it oh man there are some [ __ ] you're
doing with the public yeah no [ __ ] i
know like i said i never worked in food
service but i worked in retail and [ __ ]
man we had our own share
i used to love here is my favorite thing
and i'm sure anybody that's worked in
retail or in food service probably has
this too but you always had the [ __ ]
that would come in
and gripe about the prices and they
would like yell at me
yeah about this because the oh the cds
were too expensive or something i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i didn't price the [ __ ] yeah
yeah i just work here for minimum wage
okay get the [ __ ] off my ass about it i
don't know why they have to i guess
they're just like unhappy in their own
lives and they have to yell at somebody
that they feel is beneath them or
whatever but i was just kind of like
dude i have absolutely no control every
restaurant i always worked at there was
at least one problem customer too it's a
customer that keeps coming back and
[ __ ] they are never satisfied with
anything that happens but the [ __ ]
still keep coming back and they'll order
something
that has to be done exactly the right
way for them and the difference between
the right way and the wrong way is just
like a hair's breath
like some
freaky ass
[ __ ] that has to have [ __ ] eggs over
easy with no [ __ ] brown crusty
crinkly things on them at all it has to
almost look like a poached egg
but it can't be a poached egg it has to
be over easy
so you try to do that on a griddle
yeah good luck about that
you're sitting there putting a whole
bunch of oil on it and then it doesn't
really work and they try to get it to
the coolest part of the griddle and that
kind of works and then it takes forever
you're trying to get
that egg out on the plate
in time with everything else that has to
go to that table and then that [ __ ]
sends that [ __ ] egg back three or
four times no that's not nope that's it
nope nope nope you're like [ __ ] at that
point i think i'd take some eggs out
there and shove them right up
just
send the eggs back
no that's not it and then that same
[ __ ] customer will go that was
terrible you know i i just i just don't
know why you guys can't get it right
this and that and then the [ __ ] comes
back
you know why because it's a power play
yeah every [ __ ] week they don't care
about what the how the egg is i i refuse
to believe that they're that picky they
just like having power over peons
people that they feel beneath because
like i said they're unhappy they're at
the bottom of the totem pole yeah and
they just want to pick on somebody they
think is beneath them yeah and so they
go around acting like the [ __ ]
queen mother in that particular case we
never saw the customer though it was the
[ __ ] waitress that was taking all the
[ __ ] that's what i'm saying and it's
just kind of she's like [ __ ] i didn't
make your eggs yeah and she goes that
woman's back
the egg woman's back the egg woman
yeah yeah it's like that
i mean i really
why why why would you want to like spend
your entire life just making everyone
else's lives i'm never coming i'm never
coming back here this [ __ ] place is
just
two weeks later back
i don't think it never happened yeah
i don't know i don't understand like why
people just make it their mission in
life just to make everyone's
life harder i don't really get white
people when it's just for no reason like
for no reason
it's just like stupid petty [ __ ]
um
yeah you guys talking about michael
douglas the game actually i put that in
the poll either last week or this week
but i don't think it won
because i've been wanting to do that one
it's on hulu or amazon prime or
something like that camp guy said um he
was saying that he didn't really like to
he's like i'm kind of leery to eat at a
small family-owned restaurant unless i
know it's clean seen too many restaurant
impossible and the other shows yeah and
it really does seem like
i don't know
just us
i think there shouldn't be any problem
for the most part is although you
shouldn't wreck it well it depends look
at all the restaurants they had on
gordon ramsay's show those were all like
you can recognize a good one just by how
clean it how clean a front a house is
and uh
you you can just tell
sometimes
uh it's you can tell a shady one just
well i mean if you go into the dining
room and the dining room is like dirty
is dirty or like has does well that's
why gordon goes in there and like checks
the light fixtures and [ __ ] like that
cause he's like the [ __ ] aren't
cleaning this they're probably not clean
in the kitchen either which is a good
rule of thumb
i can look at the menu and see what
they're serving and get an idea what
their kitchen looks like back there
and you know what i mean if it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you would see on on a menu
back in the 80s or the 90s you walk out
because it's gonna be a bunch of stodgy
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
no
but that was one of my favorite things
to watch on
the on gordon ramsay show like kitchen
nightmares was i really loved all of
those terrible restaurants that uh that
only blue hairs would come too yep those
are the ones that you want to stay away
from like that like that one what was
that one fleming's fleming's terrible
and it was a smorgasbord yeah no it was
danish danish it was danish yeah that's
right yeah but it wasn't a smorgasbord
no it was just like a danish restaurant
in
miami in miami florida
which miami that's cuban food yeah
gordon kicked that place in the balls
he's like look at right next to their
right next to your place this is where
you're losing all your [ __ ] ass here
they got a fish and chest place over
here it's like a great you know and it's
just like any and you know
and he he stood out there and floridians
are walking by and he goes you've ever
been to fleming's right now
and this is
and and and he says it's a danish
restaurant and they were like oh okay he
goes can you name a danish dish and
they're like no
cheese what is date what is
[Laughter]
you
good
gordon's like yeah that's what i've been
asking myself what is that you know and
and then you go on the
look on the menu and it was just
bland
[ __ ]
the dude that owned the place just kept
the menu the same and it was the same
menu from like it's probably the 60s or
the 70s and
that's that food probably really wasn't
even popular in the 60s or the 70s but
it's customer-based long dead those
people yeah it was like all old people
yeah and the whole inside of the place
was pink yeah yeah it's horrible looking
food goes in goes in and out of style it
does
all right and uh the main customer base
was something from the 70s all right
70s and 80s when those people had money
those people are all dead now yeah all
right they're dead
they've been dead for 20 30 years you
know or 20 years so they were dying then
and
so what was left is people octogenarians
and only a few of those but the main
you want people in their 30s and 40s you
know what i mean people who are earning
money 50s that's what you're looking for
people who are retired they don't have
enough disposable income to really
fuel a restaurant off of
the restaurant's supposed to be cool
people in and out the door spending a
lot of money a lot of sides
if you can get them for drinks that's
even better drinks and desserts
that's where the real profit makers are
and uh old people you're not gonna get
that out of them so you don't even need
them
it's kind of reminded me of that kitchen
nightmares that they did like the the uk
one remember that restaurant the priory
yeah like the priority it was like yeah
and it was all old people and the
manager
gave everybody coupons so all the old
people were in there like two for one
yeah it was like two for one so it's
like all the cheap ass old people that
were on like fixed incomes would come in
there and eat and it was like a buffet
like right or like a smorgasbord type
situation yeah and they would cook that
they would re-cook all the [ __ ] over and
over again it was all dry
because they couldn't throw any stuff
out they were just
there was no profit in what they were
doing they were slowly sinking you know
and
they were like well [ __ ] we can't get
rid of the priory
we can't get rid of the [ __ ]
smorgasbord stuff
or the buffet
we'll lose all our customers
and [ __ ] gordon's trying to shove the
dude's face in the books those aren't
customers all right you're not making
enough off that customer thing to even
keep this place afloat you have to get
rid of those people and replace them
with people that have money who are
younger
because you want to work you want to
build up a customer base that will be
with you for like a long time right like
not people with one foot in the grave
yeah they drop off every year
and they're not being replaced
because your food's [ __ ] out of style
you know well that was that's what the
deal with fleming's was
people in that area didn't even know
what danish food was those customers are
long dead
yeah that was just kind of i mean [ __ ]
the food they were serving in there and
i'm that show was like several years old
but the food they were serving in there
that was like old people food when i was
a kid yeah that was like stuff that like
your grandparents would go out and eat
and be like oh it's fancy you know what
i mean it doesn't have any spice in it
it'd be that kind of stuff it doesn't
have any spice in it at all yeah
everything just tastes everything just
tastes like pepper
paprika oh my god yeah
all right it's too much yeah most people
didn't have any seasoning
so he just asked the [ __ ] chef he
goes do you know how to cook he's oh
yeah i know how to cook you just what is
all this because i don't know i think he
goes what do you cook and he goes cuban
food because we're going to be a cupid
restaurant he goes and kicks ass yeah
basically bad yeah the dude could
actually yeah he was just kind of
[ __ ] mine is yeah [ __ ] miami
you're talking about cuban food yeah
that's what they eat yeah
so you know
and cuban food's [ __ ]
far superior to some [ __ ] bland
old-fashioned danish food if you went to
go to daneland or whatever that is that
there's somebody
whatever whatever what is that place
denmark denmark
i don't [ __ ] know man
this country is like the size of posted
stamps they're always changing this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all absorbed into one another over the
years if you you go to denmark today and
probably hey the show this let's get
some [ __ ] local ethnic food if you'd
probably compare what was on that menu
to what they're eating today over there
it's probably no comparison they're like
you guys are eating that that's [ __ ]
from the 50s yeah it's like that was
what our great grandparents what the
[ __ ] are you thinking yeah well yeah
it's just like everything else like i
said especially nowadays with the
proliferation of the internet and all
these cooking shows and stuff like that
everybody's foodies like all over the
[ __ ] world so you can't really get
away with
having a restaurant like that really
anymore i'm sure that there's some that
were kind of like still limping along
but
you just really can't there's too much
competition and there's too much good
[ __ ] out there
camp guys said some of those places on
those shows are so dirty i can't imagine
how they get passed by the health
department i guess maybe some states
don't really have strict enforcement
yeah or they don't have enough people to
you know to go out and enforce so it's
like you might be have a health
inspector come in like every couple of
years or something like that you know
because they just don't have the staff
yeah and probably in probably
each estate because you know when you
say united states people think that each
one that's some kind of uniform [ __ ]
cohesive body it's not it's 50 different
states broken up into counties
some of those states if that might a
health inspection might be something
that that the county does
so in a state like that not all the
counties are going to be equal
some of the
less densely populated counties might
not have the money to run something like
that yeah they might just have one dude
might have one dude yeah so and he
doesn't have time to like go around and
inspect he can't check them all or he's
somebody's brother-in-law and he has no
intention of putting in a day's work at
all that's another thing yeah
you assume that government is meant to
function it's not it's just to keep your
brother-in-law
in work
that includes the military a lot of
those generals are in there because
that's where rich people stuff their
loser kids
make them a general
put them in the pentagon and they don't
ever do a [ __ ] day of work
you know it's like a [ __ ] welfare
program
so um
a lot of the governments are like that
um
county governments they'll run a little
election be like [ __ ]
some weird [ __ ] like you know aldermen
of [ __ ] you know
soho county population [ __ ] 500 you
know
what does the job entail you're the
alderman what do you do you sit at home
and make uh twelve hundred dollars a
watch yeah you basically just sit around
yeah nothing nothing
and watch porn watch porn
go to a meeting what are we gonna do at
the meeting we're gonna meet
we're gonna meet and we're gonna eat
donuts yeah good meeting y'all yeah
yeah let's get back to our porn yeah
you can go to these state governments
and you'll see these big monumental
looking [ __ ]
monumental offices they look like
[ __ ]
huge [ __ ] buildings and [ __ ] you know
like the looks like the [ __ ] pentagon
or something boy there must be some
serious [ __ ] going on in there
mindlessly millions of people behind
desks pressing buttons and [ __ ] me
they press a button and something
happens on the other side of the [ __ ]
state you go in there and it's [ __ ]
empty
empty
empty tables everywhere
used to be typewriters and [ __ ] on those
and then there used to be [ __ ]
pcs on those tables now there's nothing
there
because
that department that used to have
[ __ ] a thousand people in it now
staffed by 20. and they're all at home
working on working online through
laptops
that's literally what it's like a lot of
those state buildings now
and even the federal ones are more like
monuments to a past all that shit's
technologically obsolete most of your
government's in cyberspace
you don't need a building for that
they're not
typewriters and piles of paper and
shredding documents they do that but a
lot of that's busy work and it's not as
many people as it used to be
but they'll blow up a whole office to
try to get more people working to make
more parasites basically they're just
living off [ __ ] government attacks
but it's because somebody says look man
um we're gonna open up a new office
office of jacking off okay yeah yeah
office of jacking off we're gonna do
that um we're gonna have 5 000 people
working in the office of jacking off and
then they're going to come up this big
scheme on how they're going to filter
the [ __ ] money through all their
friends and then put all their friends
on the payroll and officer jacking off
doesn't even doesn't they'll build the
building and everything there's nothing
in it they're all working from home
jacking off from home on their laptops i
hope they're jacking up
there's nothing there don't jack off in
the office yeah
shouldn't need to be said but i'm gonna
say it anyway
uh raptor's ex-cop he knows
tammy says uh going back to what we're
saying about restaurants i heard the
rudest customers are the after church
crowd i have heard that also uh
everybody i know that has worked in a
restaurant has told me that uh yeah the
after church crowd is the worst rudest
and like shittiest tippers and i'm sure
like that's you know that's a
generalization but i've just heard that
from uh multiple independent sources so
i have no i have no cause to doubt it
um
yeah camp guys said i used to hate it
when customers had a lot of
modifications to the sandwiches we
offered
that's yeah i was reading an article the
other day about
man if you're gonna give like i don't
have a problem if you're just gonna go
over there let's say you're ordering a
sandwich it's like hey can you just like
leave off the onions or something like
that like that's not a big deal but if
you're going in the [ __ ] and essentially
like making them make a whole thing just
for you that's like not even on the menu
like that's a dick move
i used to go right up to a
to a starbucks
almost every day to go get some coffee
go [ __ ] hang out there get my daily
ride and then that ride back
and i show up there i remember when i
first started going up there this is uh
and they said you know
i was kind of like i didn't know what a
starbucks was when i first started going
there i just knew it was just coffee and
this is what what can i do if you say i
like a coffee what kind of coffee would
you like just some coffee coffee you
know
there's no such thing as just coffee
yeah and you're like
i was getting kind of confused what kind
of coffee do you want eventually they
realized that they didn't have to ask me
anything they just [ __ ] have some
whatever just take it just whatever
hot coffee i want you
and then they had a little picky yeah
and then they had all this [ __ ] fancy
[ __ ] about vintay and trente and [ __ ]
like that and i said look i don't know
what the [ __ ] you're talking about i
don't speak italian 20 30 what's that
how many ounces what did you call it a
lot i'm small medium large because
that's their small every other place
does that
but small mom made him a large but
starbucks that's their thing they're
trying to be all fancy i used to make
fun of them stop trying to be fancy you
know this is [ __ ] just coffee
it's not even that good
dunkin donuts had better coffee well it
depends on what kind of cot like i like
starbucks like they're they're cold
mixed drinks like yeah yeah like they're
frappuccinos and that kind of stuff
those are those are really good like i
like the java chip one and all that kind
of stuff but the hot coffee yeah i mean
it's like a milkshake essentially that's
why it's good yeah but um but yeah so
and their lattes and stuff like that are
good but their hot coffee is
is hit or miss honestly hot coffee
duncan is better yeah mcdonald's is
better yeah mcdonald's uh 7-eleven real
good has actually better coffee
than well the thing about starbucks and
a lot of people complain about it is
that they over roast their beans so a
lot of people say that they're various
they have different roasts but a lot of
them say like it tastes burned and
people have speculated that maybe they
do that because usually they're mixing
the coffee with other things like to
make a frappuccino or whatever so they
want it to have like a stronger flavor
to sort of offset the sweetness from all
the other stuff i don't know if that's
true or not but that's what i've heard
but a lot of people have complained that
their coffee tastes burned i never
thought it tasted burned but i don't
usually get hot coffee from there i
usually get like a mixed thing yeah cam
got that mcdonald's vanilla iced coffee
man that's that's [ __ ] good man
really good i always get the hazelnut
that's good too i got that i got one of
those last night actually yeah that's
good too but yeah it's probably just
artificial flavoring but it's it's i'm
sure it is it's good though but it's
good yeah
so it's almost time for a step off this
isn't a whole night a side track we've
been on for about an hour
uh 45 minutes yeah i'm gonna i gotta get
that pizza ready all right oh slasher
fred just said in the 80s the wendy's
used to have a salad bar i remember that
yeah i remember you could go you could
punish them for that too
[Laughter]
and i'd [ __ ] it's like oh i can eat a
lot yeah
you're gonna rue the day i came into
this one
you just scoop it all up and take it
back to your table
i'll be taking this whole tin of
tomatoes yeah
i punished them and i punished the
chinese
putting that shrimp out there that
[ __ ] boiled shrimp don't you ever put
boiled shrimp out there on a [ __ ]
all-you-can-eat [ __ ] chinese buffet
tom will just inhale it you'll regret
that
you will regret that we've many times
many times about we've gone to koi wan
and like we've just eaten between him
and me because i'll eat some of the like
scallops and stuff towards the little
oysters or whatever they'll stop putting
it out they'll just stop they're just
like god damn it
they'll stop putting it out because
we've eaten it all
[ __ ] piles up
and then except they're like shut shrimp
down
until that guy leaves they're abusing it
well you can eat a lot more than i can i
said well because i like when i go there
because i can only eat really like a
plate and a half before i feel like i'm
gonna hurl so i ha i like to get like a
little bit of each thing so i get like a
teaspoon of this thing and a teaspoon of
this thing but i'll get like several
shrimp because i can eat a lot of you
can get you could go to koi wan which is
chinese disneyland really it's beautiful
on the inside chinese buffet it's got an
indoor [ __ ] koi pond with a [ __ ]
indoor river that goes down through the
side of the down restaurant with
[ __ ] bridges that little
bridges that [ __ ] arch over it to go
into the dining room
and when you come out of the dining room
it looks like you're outside kinda you
know what i mean like you're going from
the street that's you know the hibachi
and the gre and all that kind of [ __ ]
supposed to be like you're getting it
off the street you notice that yeah it's
supposed to well that yeah they look
like a chinese street with a [ __ ]
yeah it's like cobblestone like the
floor kind of looks like cobblestones
and they have like little kind of fake
trees and stuff so it kind of looks like
it's outdoors yeah like a like a market
or something it's like chinese
disneyland yeah so um
it
i think it was about 10 for the
all-you-can-eat buffet but you could
upgrade it to like for twenty dollars
you could get the all you can eat buffet
that comes with that all you can eat
shrimp
a boiled shrimp and for the twenty
dollars they'll [ __ ] let throw in all
you can eat crab legs
i punished them for that too i can eat a
lot of i can eat a lot of them to have
crab legs and crabs
i think crab legs slowly vanished
off that menu
well i think when they're only when they
and they're available i guess well no i
think that you can only get the crab
legs deal like after 4 p.m i think it's
after 4 p.m is what it is like if you go
because we usually go around lunch time
yeah like uh 11 or 12 and i don't think
you can get it then i think that's just
a dinner then just dinner thing okay
well we have to make our way back down
here eventually where i'll punish them
for offering that because they will live
to regret it
offered me crab legs i'll clean them out
i'll be standing there just waiting for
the crab legs to be delivered that's
where they
just take them all put and i have a
bunch of different plates i have a
plate with all the [ __ ] crab legs the
plate with the [ __ ] my sauces and all
the them butter and another couple of
empty plates for all the husks yeah and
he's got it all girls come taken up and
then he has a plate with a bunch of like
lemon wedges on it so he can wash his
hands yeah
he's got it all planned out it's
a [ __ ] crab consumption center
like a control room
you know
yeah
which like i said usually when i go i'll
get like a plate with like a lit with a
few like boiled shrimp and then like a
couple of scallops and then sometimes
i'll get some wonton soup depending on
how hungry i am and then i'll kind of go
through that and then i'll go back and
get another plate with just like a
teaspoon of a bunch of other things i
usually stick with seafood dishes
and
um
meat and vegetables i don't usually do i
love like lo mein and stuff like that
but i don't get like lo mein or rice or
anything like that because that's just
like it's too filling i'll just get like
pepper steak or if they have any kind of
like uh steamed fish or
anything like that and then sometimes
i'll get some dumplings but john smith's
got it right yes this question so tom
views all you can eat as both a
challenge and an insult yes yes exactly
now you understand it
you know you know you you understand it
now i'm like what oh i'm enough i'm
gonna [ __ ] you up for that
all you could eat
the audacity of offering all you know
you
[Laughter]
i'm going to put that to the test yeah
i'm going to try to eat i'm going to eat
an amazing amount
for seafood
of seafood yeah seafood yeah certain
things i can't eat that much of it but
shrimp oh man i could eat pounds and
pounds of it
same thing with crabs
and uh
lobster tails i could just [ __ ] one
time in egypt i just [ __ ] stuffed
myself with them i must
must have ate about they
15 of them
they were the smaller ones yeah
but uh
the british cooks down at south camp on
the mfo mission
[ __ ] served them okay israel sent and
sent them to us
were kind of like tribute i guess
because we were enforcing a peace treaty
there
and um
they were up there on the line man and
[ __ ] everybody was passing them up
and plugging the british guys the cook's
got pisses man we got you guys got
lobster nobody's taking it
and looking
the guys that did love it and somebody i
ain't that looks like a bug you know a
lot of guys just [ __ ] you know
never had a bug looks like a bug
no the lobster eaters just all went to
the [ __ ] same group of four or five
tables and just cleared them out it says
don't worry man we're not gonna because
they're like we can't you can't store
this stuff one thing we can do is make
lobster bisque afterwards with this we
gotta eat it that's what the cooks told
us yeah she's like all right we're gonna
put this [ __ ] to the test i must ate 15
of them things
and then took a couple of them back with
me probably four or five of them back to
the barracks
and ice in a bucket of
ice after this and i ended up
um
putting it in a bucket full of ice from
the [ __ ] ice machine and they chilled
it
it wasn't quite as good but it was okay
later on that night i was eating some
more but i got sick of it i had a whole
soup bowl full of [ __ ] butter
pulling that [ __ ]
and it's just guys so there's no reason
to use knives and forks you know what i
mean it's not like you're in public
you know there are no ladies
so you can just act like a caveman yeah
i just [ __ ] can't man a child [ __ ]
burp [ __ ] there's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] scratcher balls there's
[ __ ] no you got [ __ ] butter on
your hands man you're in uniform buttery
balls yeah you're a youth
but no [ __ ] around the table you had
[ __ ] uh
you had [ __ ] lobster tail husks
falling off the [ __ ] table you know
the floor is like a ring of lobster tail
we picked them all up but well that's
good
it's funny
yeah we've been drinking too you know we
were well that's we were off to at least
a reason
yeah lyrica dude says i want an all you
can eat international buffet the finest
from around the world that's actually a
good idea i wonder why anybody's done
that i mean i guess you can kind of do
that if you go to epcot like you can eat
around the world but it's not really the
same thing it's like it would be cool if
it would be like all in one building
and you just like a lot of dishes i know
but well you could just like pick a
handful from you know you don't have to
have have every country in the world
because a lot well koi is kind of like
that
because it's got japanese chinese
american italian-american remember for
like the kids yeah for kids because
because it has this yeah like chicken
nuggets and
spaghetti and [ __ ] for little kids then
there's stuff on there that's thai
yeah
so depending on the day they have
different [ __ ] like yeah
yeah it's just it's basically asian and
then they have like some american and
yeah because not everybody likes that
his whole families go so some kids don't
eat it or some people are like well i
can't eat this they got pizza on there
yeah like pizza and french fries and
[ __ ] like yeah and chicken nuggets
there's stuff that you know white rice
and potatoes and [ __ ] pieces of steak
that aren't really
asian scent flavored or anything it's
just kind of generic you know
so it doesn't have to taste chinese
there's
nothing to have koi want was just a
whole big old thing of damn sauteed
mushrooms you can just pick up they're
whole mushrooms yeah they're good oh i
always get those a lot of those i love
mushrooms it's funny because when i was
a kid i used to hate mushrooms i thought
they were disgusting but then like
something just i used to think tomatoes
were disgusting too but then like for
some reason when i got a little bit
older everything just clicked yeah now
there's two now they're two of my
favorite things yeah they're good
they're good and they're big they're
like the size of them
golf balls you can sit there and eat a
bunch of them
that butter
look we got i got to get off here guys
wait let's wait there's one more
question uh mrs evans already party says
jenny are you working on a book yes i'm
doing a
it's kind of like i'm on like chapter
six or seven
and
it's it's fiction but it's sort of based
on a real murder case but that's all i'm
gonna say about it
but it's yeah it's it's going good i
think it's gonna be good but it might be
a while i'm going to try and have it out
by the end of this year but we'll see
how it goes all right so we're going to
go
make some pizza
so thanks margarita pizza margarita
pizza yeah so thanks for hanging out
with us on this sunday have a good rest
of your weekend
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow